you know you talk about your friendship
with chris farley yeah he was such a
naturally likable funny guy i didn't
know him but um yeah but you did know
him a little bit howard because
everybody who saw him perform got a
little piece of his soul
i mean that that was the thing about
chris that was
very special and uh and undeniable and
made his potential even so much greater
than anything he'd done
uh that we that we got to see or that we
can see on tape i mean he could have
done drama and done a really beautiful
job with some some
parts as time went by if he'd stayed
alive and i i know he would have and uh
but everybody got a piece of his soul
like right away like within 20 seconds
of seeing him and that's just
you know that's rare man and and that
was true in real life and and it comes
through the screen too like you just saw
this guy's heart out
you know held out for you unbelievable
and i mean it was heartbreaking when you
write about the last time you saw him he
was in a limo with as you say a bunch of
people you wish he hadn't been with it
looked like his hanger honors it was he
was doing blows right even in the limo
yeah well i didn't see him doing blow
but that guy in there was tried to give
us blow earlier in the day
um we had a party
at a bar and somebody came in and said
farley's out back
he wants to say hi to you
i guess he felt weird about coming in
probably because he was very always very
was very aware of what he looked like
and how people were perceiving him
and uh he was pretty off the rails he
was way off the rails at this particular
event where they were also having a
saturday night live reunion event
and i'm sure people had been telling him
all weekend what the hell is going on
with you chris go to rehab right now
you shouldn't be here don't go off with
those people i'm sure he was hearing
that all weekend and uh
so he didn't want to come in so i went
out back
this limousine window crack comes down
and chris looked worse than i'd ever
seen him
and and we just had a nice chat and he
was
out of it a bit and the worst thing
about it all howard was my dad was an
alcoholic and i was around
and came to understand alcoholism
because of that
um even as a teenager and uh
that feeling
of inevitability that i write about was
the worst part of it all because you
love this guy and everybody loved him i
i'm not special in that way and uh
that horrible feeling of like this
goddamn story is just gonna play out
and the corniest [ __ ] way
that any that even chris could have told
you even chris would have told you
this is what i'm gonna do
and i'm gonna die and i'm gonna be 30 by
the way 33 when belushi died same age
like what the [ __ ]
you know i
i think you see a lot of people talk
about chris i imagine younger people
who hear all these stories about chris
wonder what what was this guy like i
mean you know
he was a silly funny performer but
i guess i feel like if you watch him
you have to see what we're talking about
all the people who knew him you have to
see that
piece of his heart that he brought to
everything
yeah you always um were critical of that
sketch the famous sketch with patrick
swayze where chris gets up and uses his
belly and his body and the joke
basically is he's fat that chippendale
sketch is kind of unique
chris didn't feel like he was on sure
footing at snl yet that was the first
big
sort of present moment for him so if it
hadn't been the first one that might
have made it a little less egregious to
me
but it was
um
i got it maybe it's just me watching it
but i've always felt like that moment
where he pulls his shirt off
there's almost a hesitation i see in his
eyes
and and even the
the smile or the kind of
expression on his face
i just get a queasy feeling that he
knows
a good chunk of this reaction is because
of my
body
shape and
he's a loving he's loving the laugh
he's loving the reaction that he knows
he's going to get because he got it
anytime he did that or anything like it
but he's
feeling like
he you know chris would walk around
saying
i'm going to use words you're not
supposed to use i'm a [ __ ]
and fatty fall down he would say all the
time he'd fall down and say he fall down
and
and things like he would refer to
himself with the derogatory terms
and so just that moment
i just hated that moment i still do i
wish it hadn't been the first big thing
that happened to him and i don't like
that you know people pretend that
somehow the big laugh from that sketch
was the concept of it which was the
judges
can't really say why patrick swayze is a
better chippendales dancer than chris
farley
i yeah i get it that that's the joke but
there are people the audience is
responding to his
physical
uh in your mind it's a cheap laugh and
also you know so he tells chris
exactly what he shouldn't be
hearing
which is that's why you're funny because
you're
stupid and big
and right
not
you know you the
that's not why he was lovable and funny
and worth watching and worth being
around
uh and it just it just sent that message
it just
it was a bad uh
exchange
and it i i felt i've always felt bad
about it i've always felt like it was a
not the right thing